well meantime some former and current
students dug up a time capsule that was
buried out in front of a Richard H Brian
Elementary School they did it 25 years
ago yeah students came up with the idea
to celebrate the opening of the school
back in 1998 eight news now
photojournalist Henry takai takes us
back in time
it was driven by the kids I mean again
we wanted to memorialize this brand new
building fantastic new school that we
had through one of those brainstorming
sessions we somebody brought up the idea
to bury a time capsule
I remember planning it because we were
in the gate class which was the class
that kind of was in charge of planning
25 25 years we have the article so that
was nice to reflect on it's very
nostalgic bringing up a lot of memories
that you like kind of forgot about right
yeah
[Applause]
every row I know there was a lot of like
writing from each class that each
student did
the TV Guide this is seriously Rugrats I
do remember putting newspapers that was
one of the main things that I I remember
and the small five and a quarter floppy
discs it's just fantastic to see all the
successes you know stories that uh from
each of those those kids it really means
a lot to me they're going to continue to
do that and I hope we're all around to
come back and enjoy that as well